sup Internet so today we're gonna do an
After Effects quick tip for you guys you
see all these things tracked into the
scene it took me like two minutes to put
together with the camera tracker but a
little trick involved too so let's go
over that right now you ready let's do
this okay so first things first take
your footage and drop it into a new
composition like I did and what we're
gonna do is we're going to use the
camera tracker and track our footage so
select your footage hit track camera and
now it's gonna analyze in the background
now we have a few different options for
doing this we can either point track it
or you can kick it out to mocha and you
know track it that'll give you a great
results or you can personally keyframe
it each and every frame and that's just
a nightmare don't do that
so the other option is to track your
camera so when you camera tracked
something you have to actually have a 3d
layer anything you tracking to the scene
needs to be 3d and if I for instance
wanted to drop this monster of a animal
we'll get out frightening that is don't
want to say track him into the shot I
have to actually make it a 3d layer but
the issue which I'll get to in a moment
once this is done solving okay so now
that it's done solving I can create a
new camera
if you select your plugin there select
some points right click and create Knoll
and camera so now our scene is 3d
tracked we have a null object in the
scene what is the 3d null object so if I
was to pull in this footage of this
crazy terrible wolf and try to track it
to that alright moving on if I take our
lair and track it to this 3d null object
it's not going to actually do anything
because it's a 2d layer linked to a 3d
null object so what we need to do is
actually convert that 3d null into a 2d
normal and so this is what we're gonna
do first we're gonna name our 3d null
object just call it 3d null because I'm
super original go to layer new null
object and this is a 2d null object but
you can't just link that to the 3d null
object either so I'm gonna hit P to pull
down the position if you hold down the
alt oh hold on the alt button and then
click the stopwatch delete that text
there and pick whip this expression to
your 3d null object and that
basically just identifies it it gives it
the name and now this is where you have
to actually be really specific in how
you type this next part out hit period
to capital C for comp and then open
parenthesis open brackets that's not a
bracket this is a bracket 0 comma 0
comma 0 close bracket close parenthesis
enter now it's a 2d null tract into the
scene you see that and now we can
literally just turn off our other null
don't delete it and don't double click
on it so now we can take our image here
and link it to the null object which I'm
going to call 2d you know gotta be
organized man this is the already nice
Hey look at that now it's tracked into
the shot that's amazing
and that was super easy to do there is a
huge downside to this tip and that is
the fact that it does not take into
account rotation and scale so if you
need those you're gonna need to actually
make sure it's track properly but if
it's just a simple pan or something you
want something tracked into the
background for instance because there's
parallax in this shot I can track it
something to the ground here right click
create null and change the name of this
2d one or it says three-needle I'm going
to make it source the other null which I
called now let's tract to the ground
here I can do the same thing if I made a
knoll for the background it's great if
you like these kind of quick tips
tutorials maybe we can do some more if
you have any other ideas for things you
want to do I want to hear them and until
next time
[Music]
Hey got my